[Music]
you love Halloween what's your costume
gonna be this year you usually make your
own costume yes I make it's important I
think I don't like the guys who go to
buy like the $20 SpongeBob SquarePants
thing store I just it's the best I could
do we work on we're gonna work on I'm
gonna give you all my old costumes I'm
gonna have it lengthened this year I
have grand plans I got one of these
backpacks that has the metal frame on
the back a 100 and 250 pounds some like
that and I got this metal frame and I'm
going to construct this giant skeleton
puppet I want to operate the arms from
down low it's gonna be amazing to be
huge I'm gonna and I but I want it to be
but you know impressive so I'm gonna
construct it out of metal I'm gonna weld
it together and it's gonna be able to
pick up a child you know I'm gonna be
[Laughter]
you're gonna wander the neighborhood
picking up children you don't know in a
strange device you're gonna get in
trouble it's gonna happen what do you
mean you're gonna weld it do well yes
IRA well but I took up I took up welding
this is like a thing I wanted to what
made you do that you know everybody
likes to be handy Yeah right I wish I
was hander than I am but yeah as Gabriel
every guy wants to be hand we all have
our limitations and if you look as like
a that's metal on metal can't be done
can't be done
you're a welder now I can do it now I
can put that it's not it's not to be
taken lightly there's some equipment you
have to get the equipment
you gotta the Machine you gotta gloves
you could have a good leather apron you
can have a mask you got it this there's
molten spatter that metal will spit off
of this thing and you could feel it
hitting the top of your head you smell
the hair I don't have to tell you how
important hair is so you're gonna have a
hat you gotta have I have a water bottle
nearby squirt squirt just to see what
you put fires out on your head as you
know amazing well yes people I have a
little fire extinguisher next to my
thing you don't want to you learn you
learn as you go
I have you know I my very first
experiment welding I said oh my god it
works
packed everything away and I said this
is gonna be great I went to put away the
piece I was welding and I burned myself
clean across my hand this perfectly
straight line of a blister across my
palm but then there's a mixed blessing
in that for a week I couldn't shake
anybody's hand say sorry I can't die
burn myself welding one of my hobbies is
is zombie apocalypse preparedness I
think it's very you want to be in when
the zombie apocalypse comes cuz we know
it will come eventually you want to be
ready when you're on a plane Tony and
someone comes for the from the pop
cockpit and says can anyone here fly a
plane if the guy next to you says I can
you're saying oh my god this guy's
everybody this guy right right right now
there's gonna be when the zombie
apocalypse happens like we need to get
from point A to point B we need to
somehow fortify this SUV so we can go
and does armies look it in can anybody
here weld
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it also works out too because
nobody wants that guy to get eaten so
everybody will work extra hard to keep
his over that's a fantastic I I just I
love it I love that you weld I want a
weld I want to learn to weld isn't
something that you think that I could
learn
it's not easy Conan welding is like
being a Greek god forging metal to metal
merging it with fire thinking it to get
it's amazing it's by cool I've got to
wrap your child horse I didn't know I
guess like being a great guy there's a
course at the new school